she really said can I have you as a pet
or I'm gonna kill you yeah literally
what's going on people today my
girlfriend who knows nothing about anime
is going to be reacting to episode one
of Chainsaw man but before we get into
it I guess you should just tell everyone
how much you know about chainsaw man in
general if anything
um I guess I just know the name
I've heard you mention the name
I don't I don't even know what it looks
like what the premise is
are you an anime fan in general no
how much how much anime or Manga
knowledge do you have do you think I've
watched the first four episodes of my
hero Academia yeah that's true that was
ages ago that was like two years ago
there wasn't maybe three you took me to
see the my hero Academia film one of
them that's true that's true you fell
asleep I slept
um and then the odd videos that we've
done here where I've guessed the quirks
of certain characters and stuff like
that yeah awesome okay well that's
lesson on the first episode okay
why am I nervous I feel like I know
nothing I just oh he's down bad yeah
yeah
there's a chainsaw yeah
drinks or dog yeah
so that is a devil it looks like a
cursed Strawberry yes it's the tomato
tomato yeah
um so while the while the intro's
playing I guess I can just give you a
few Basics to know so in this world
there are like these things called
devils and basically every devil
represents a fear that humans have so
like let's say people are afraid of
tomatoes the Tomato devil is born out of
that right and it's a devil for
everything like anything you can think
of there's a devil for it and denji
who's the main character here he's broke
and he makes money by killing these
Devils right okay so mine would be a
bird devil that would be yeah that would
be the thing that you'd be most afraid
of yeah and like your fear of birds
would make the bird devil like so strong
if there were like lots of people like
you it would get even stronger
right because like the strength of the
devil depends on
so they're like they're like gangsters
yeah
oh it's so cute the little one
oh he wouldn't really do anything for
money yeah
his teeth are so pointy
he actually didn't oh yeah
there's people like a like a shark or
something yeah
he has bigger issues right now and he's
thinking thinking about a girlfriend
yeah you need to focus on living man
this is when he's like six
[Music]
so it's a devil yeah it's a devil
oh for people who are scared of
chainsaws yeah yeah that's it but
Devil's in this universe they can
regenerate and like heal themselves if
they drink human blood sort of like
vampires yeah
oh
all about the girls again
are there other
devil hunters in this universe then yeah
but like denji's more like um
he's not legit like he's just a guy
hunting Devils but most of devons would
either get like paid by the government
like John Wick type yeah and they wear
like suits exactly like John Wick right
like they're not like him he's just just
doing out of the gangsters but there are
some people in this universe who do
devil hunting part-time
called civilian devil Hunters okay so
who do they get paid by so they get paid
by the government but they only work
part-time just they just kill whatever
devil they want to okay I feel like he's
about to get
played
uh oh
not the chainsaw yeah
are these ex-c civilian people so these
are like members of the mafia like who
were working for the old man
but they wanted to get stronger so they
made a deal with the zombie devil but
then they kind of got tricked because he
just turned them on to zombies anyways
just do what he wants go
to the exit's right there I mean I feel
like he's gonna make it if not this
would be the shortest series ever oh
they just catch him it's just like the
end yeah
oh
I was gonna say at least these aren't
like the I Am Legend type of zombies
like they're not the fast
zombies
he's getting mugged
that was done the end roll credits like
what's going on
there's no way he survived that no he
didn't
right he's dead as hell
so and like it was a lot more harrowing
like in the anime like just hearing him
scream and stuff
he said I give you full permission to
have what's left of me yeah
that's dystopian isn't it he's ripped
her yeah yeah
he's because he's barely eating anything
yeah yeah the ABS are gonna show
and he's doing manually oh
right his body's being put back together
quite literally oh wow
[Music]
imagine imagine your dog just started
speaking I don't know if you need
someone to speak to me my life would be
complete
wait is he gonna like pull on it or
something oh he is oh
Jesus what is going on also like
the little thing was so cute why is he
so he's gone yeah monstrous
because it's like because like this is a
combination of the two isn't it it's
like a whole new new thing it's still
dingy but he's got visas yeah chainsaws
now
that's the thing of being a zombie is
that you have to keep going forward even
though like you don't know why you
because I would have just run away yeah
I'm not if I see my I'm not dying for
this your friends are getting torn up in
front of you yeah yeah I'm going the
other way
but like it's interesting how strong it
made then Jake is like all this guy ate
today was like a slice of bread yeah he
was actually coughing up blood like
it's a bit of a psycho though yeah
because he could have he could leave now
babe you can go you can go home
but he's had a hard life now yeah and
you can kill the people who've been like
who've been forcing him to do all these
things yeah because the old boss was
there right yeah 38 million wiped yeah
yeah literally someone that's a lie
oh these are the John Wick type
characters I was telling you about yeah
yeah well you were telling me yeah these
are like the legit devil Hunters oh
looks so creepy mom I threw up
what was that thing creepy fingers Salad
Fingers oh my shallard finger
I think that's gonna be his girl
she really said can I have you as a pet
oh I'm gonna kill you yeah literally
that is the choice
oh cool is gonna go for the food Brett
today the dream come true yeah gets
treats yeah
so that was episode one of Chainsaw man
nice introduction yeah and like
generally the concept like what did you
think about it it's not what I imagined
I had no idea like well
the name chainsaw man I assumed that he
would be part chainsaw but I thought
it'd just be like his hand like or
something that like you know he could
use as a chainsaw I didn't think it
would like it would be in him I'm
confused well intrigued and confused as
to like
is it only when he pulls a thing
is it only when he feels a certain type
of emotion like oh whether it's like a
survival thing can he
become the chainsaw on demand you know
yeah that's interesting also just the
way it was just so monstrous when the
thing was so cute like the juxtaposition
is crazy it's true yeah like what's
going on because he is like the cutest
little thing and then that thing was
like awful and the way it melted off him
and then like yeah it was so murderous
you know but that's danger he's just
he's just a psycho I wouldn't call him
he's he's had a hard life okay he's had
a hard life you would you be Psycho too
if you had to put peace
but one thing I don't know if this will
change your opinion so like when he uses
the chainsaws he actually like he
physically feels the pain like it's like
it's digging into him as well gee and he
just continues like I don't know he's
got like his brains wired differently
yeah because like even if he feels the
pain even though it's digging into him
he's just like yeah I don't care I'm
just gonna kill these zombies
ouch that's crazy but yeah so overall if
you had to give it a rating out of 10
yeah don't feel obligated to give it 10
out of 10 like I would I mean
I guess
I'll give it like
a 6.5 6.5 yeah I feel like that's quite
generous yeah because wait you think
simplify generous bruh that is Harsh
you know there's room for it room for
improvement there I see I see okay you
need to watch I think we need to watch
some more
when we get the 3 000 likes
would you be down for that well I really
agreed yeah let's go all right cool well
thank you guys for watching this
reaction video thank you to Laverne
should people follow you on Twitter or
anything or Instagram
um I don't post enough to be that
interesting okay fair enough do not
follow her are there any circumstances
nobody follow her
cool all right well thanks for watching
the video as always guys let me know
down below your thoughts on this video
and until the next one peace out